don't lie to your kid don't sugarcoat it
don't fool around
in the long run all that stuff will just
bite you in the ass if you can't tell
the truth don't say anything
let's say your kid's in the back seat
and you're driving them home from
class and they say mommy can i stop at
mcdonald's and you know when you say no
they're going to start screaming in the
back and you don't want to hear it fine
take a few deep breaths and then say no
and brace yourself you'd be surprised
how often they
don't scream once they respect you that
your no
means no
savann how are you my friend i'm amazing
living the dream in someone else's
nightmare
i've had a couple of cracks at the intro
desperately trying to get your name
right
uh but here we are what do you think
we're going to talk about today we've
got a lot of different
avenues that we can go down what do you
reckon we're going to talk about
i am a very simple man with not a lot to
talk about so you better nail it
right on the button or else it's gonna
be a real dull point podcast
i disagree massively so okay first
question is
how come you have made a name for
yourself
doing a thing that 90 of humans do which
is
raising kids
who um i love publishing
i love creating stuff i use social media
as a
cheap publishing platform it is not
something that i use
to really scroll around on um even
though they're always tempting me in the
reels with those girls like doing all
those fancy dances and barely clothed
um and i bought a computer to uh
i got a computer and the editing
software that apple released the day
it released it in 2000 whatever
i was living in my car i plugged the
computer into my cigarette lighter and
from that day forward i've used final
cut pro adobe premiere
some video and i've been creating video
for over 20 years
tv shows movies commercials youtube
instagram and so basically what happened
is
i have my three i've been now i know
what happened i've been preparing all
these years because now i have my three
favorite subjects of all time
my three sons avi who's six
ari and joseph who are twins who are
three
and they are not only my sistine chapel
they're gonna be my greatest work ever
but i'm gonna record it because that's
what i enjoy to do
and so they do some stuff on instagram
that's got them
uh some attention and um
and so that's how our i think our paths
have crossed and we both crossfit
i think we're both sort of in that
ecosystem lots of people take videos of
the kids though
you know like it's every every mum that
i know
is so trigger happy with the camera so
how come what
what makes you worthy of people caring
what you do with them
so in um
so so one i have 20 years of experience
of creating videos so maybe i in
in my in my previous life i created more
than probably
in 2007 89 i created
i don't know i want to say a piece of
content every single day for crossfit
inc
and um there was even a joke at crossfit
inc that it should be called sevon.com
and not
crossfit.com i think there was a day
where they published my stuff 42 days in
a row in 2010.
and so i've had a ton of practice right
so i know on some level how to
um intuitively i guess um to present my
kids in a manner that would be
intriguing but not only intriguing
educational
my point my my my main goal of
publishing
is i just want to add value to people's
lives right so i want people to see
50 of it is i just like to create stuff
and on the other side
the other 50 percent is i wanted to add
value to their lives and because i'm a
crossfitter
and because i have this um
unwavering belief in the crossfit
methodology which the foundation is diet
and then up from there it's movement
and and that struggle causes adaptation
that's how i'm raising my kids
i basically there's two two basic
premises for how i'm raising my kids i'm
using the crossfit methodology
and then i'm sort of viewing using um
taoist principles or
principles of the journey to
enlightenment through like maybe
like uh vipassana or creating space or
um not stealing the mind
but watching myself and
making sure that i'm making the best
decisions
for my kids as a human being i know that
was a lot i was really trying to
condense another but those are sort of
the two outside things
you're seeing physically how i'm
training them and the things that i'm
asking them to do and show them to do
and the diet that they're consuming
on my platform but then you're also and
i've only recently
started sharing this i'm sharing with
people how
i work through the hard times
you know whether it be their temper
tantrums they're pressing back
and i do that through really in the
simplest way daoist principles
or just really really staying still and
sort of becoming
nothing and by nothing i mean no thing
not you know no thing and so that they
can
resolve their own their own problems
doesn't always
work out did you always know that
did you always know that you were going
to be some savant
sage of experimental child rearing
no no and i don't i don't um
i don't know and i don't i don't accept
that like i don't think that about
myself and i didn't know that so
uh my my wife and i
were we were married we're we're
been together 20 years and the entire
time the plan was not to get married and
not to have kids
i had no interest in it i thought people
who got married were just tools of the
man just followers
and i thought that there were enough
kids on the planet who am i to
contribute what can i contribute
and then some and then we were living
with some friends and they had a baby
so we were in a house and now there's a
baby and then my
closest friend in life he had a baby and
somehow that triggered my wife
at 39 years old to be like hey i want a
baby so we had a baby
and it was just like i mean it was so
just casual
um and
something happened i i can't like
biologically emotionally mentally
um there's this dao was saying stop
thinking and all your problems will go
away
and that's basically at i'm 48 years old
um and i point my age out because my 30s
were my grinding years so i don't know
how this would have turned out if i
would have had a kid at 34 because i was
so you know i i shot movies in 100
different countries
i mean i was on the ball and
so now i don't want to do anything
something just happened i don't want to
do anything but be with my kids
that's it like i have no like
that's it i don't i don't that's
terrifying to hear man
like that absolutely terrifies me and
i've been talking about this a lot
especially this year that
there is an archetype for women who
hit sort of 30 and then perhaps start to
get a little bit more serious about
settling down
but for men i don't think that we quite
have that and we lived through
archetypes right we lived through these
sort of
cliche grand narratives where we look up
to the classic
roles that people play in movies or in
books or whatever it might be and there
isn't an equivalent for the
young guy who has served his time
burning the candle at both ends
and now really once a family likes the
idea of a family
and to hear that that there is a switch
somewhere inside of us that none of us
knew even existed
and at some point all of the other guys
who are listening
who have been loving being independent
sovereign agents with upward mobility
and freedom to do whatever they wanted
i'm going to dubai tomorrow because i
can
what's the point in having [ __ ] you
freedom if you never say [ __ ] you and
at some point i can potentially have
this switch turned on
which completely flattens my entire
world view
and makes me become at the mercy of
these
little miracle creatures that i've just
brought into the world
and the rest of my life's going to stop
that's like beautiful
and terrifying at the same time
let me let me maybe i'll shed some light
on it and i don't know if what i'm
saying is true
but let's say that we go out in search
of life and when we go out we're just
mirrors and we're just looking for
perfect reflections of ourselves right
and so that's the struggle of life that
we can't find that perfect reflection so
we move from relationship to
relationship and coffee shop to coffee
shop and job this job and buying car to
car
and we're either trying to scratch
something inside or outside but we're
looking for that perfect reflection
maybe i've never explored this except
for just now
maybe what happens is these guys came
out
and they just start reflecting me
perfectly
and bam they got me why do you think the
reflection
is what we're looking for
through my personal experience
of what i call
watching my mind but some people call
meditating watching
it's not just my mind it's watching my
body all sensations
i see things arise whether it be a
scratch on my arm
or a thought that i'm hungry or oh my
toe hurts or oh my back hurts
and they come in sensations and words
and emotions
there is then a desire to
move or act to alleviate or
respond to that
sensation thought whatever came out of
you so you look for an
external
fulfillment you look for something
externally instead of letting it
pass so you're hungry i'm working on my
computer editing a podcast it's 10
o'clock at night i'm hungry
i turn the volume up on the podcast so i
can hear it as i go to the kitchen and
stuff myself with two handfuls of
macadamia nuts right
or i could just let that pass it and it
is gonna pass but most people
i i shouldn't say this in the past in my
life as i grew up i wouldn't let that
pass i would itch
every single and so that's where i come
up with the mirror
the mirror thing we're looking for
something outside of us to alleviate the
discomforts that come
inside that's why people lie and just
all sorts of if you're looking to
alleviate discomfort it's sort of
and that's what makes us kind of like
flies we twitch from one pile of [ __ ] to
the next because
we're looking to alleviate discomfort
and and i use the word discomfort super
broad
like you know and so
the goal would be to just um let those
things well
different subject but when i'm around my
kids i'm especially focused on letting
those things pass
and it's pretty easy to let those things
pass because they're giving me every
i need did you own a dog they're
reflecting me perfectly did you want a
dog before you had kids
great question yes
i did own a dog i had three great danes
in my motorhome and then i had this
little after that i have this little
tiny chihuahua
okay which was harder to raise
the danes it's a lot of [ __ ] it's a lot
of [ __ ]
they oh man i you i saw like morning
peas that would be like two minutes long
from my dog it's just destroying gardens
and like
i mean it's ammonia everywhere
yeah danes are so much harder okay so i
think
that people who are considering having
children
really couples really should try and
raise
something that's a similarly dependent
i.e
you know a dog or i get a cat even cats
are too
independent right um i definitely think
that that's a nice on-ramp
did it prepare you did having dogs
before help to prepare you for having
kids
i i don't know
but i will say that the dog
be when i would hear people get have
kids and then they would say they
neglect their dog i would be like i
would never do that i would never
neglect my dog
i was wrong i absolutely neglect my dog
i used to spend a lot of time with my
dog
now i spend zero time with my dog i mean
the dog i just opened the car door and
he jumps in
and then when we get home i open it and
he gets out like i don't know you know
what
he's an accessory so i feel bad for him
my wife is much kinder to him and still
gives
them attention but i don't know if it
made me better but but i buy it
i buy what you're saying okay okay so
you hadn't planned
some some arguments might arise right i
mean as superficial as it sounds
when you have a kid like are you going
to circumcise the kid or you're not
going to circumcise the kid
are you going to send him to school or
you're not going to send him to school
is it okay that he choose gum is it not
okay that he choose gum i see couples
fighting about that [ __ ]
everywhere i go it's it's
and so if you get a dog maybe like you
guys will argue over grain free
food or spending extra money to get raw
food and you guys can
work out some of those um
work out some of those problems have
some arguments and see how it's going to
go well learning how to negotiate when
a third party is dependent on you is
very different to what most couples have
until that happens right
i want this you want that
maybe my parents think that we should do
this
but they're not a dependent they're just
a third party sticking their nose in
and making life a bit more difficult um
but yeah i think
i think that the the dog thing is a good
starting point okay so
you've had dogs you say at 39 for your
misses
um which is quite late i guess by by
normal standards now
although more women had children under
the age
over the age of 40 than under the age of
20 last year
in the uk which is a wonderful
unbelievable statistic
um so you decide to have kids
39 and you were
i'm 48 now my oldest is six so i must
have been 42 or 43.
yeah what what what happened there the
switch the switch gets flicked on but
you don't know none of this
you don't know that you need to build
i'm jumping ahead but you don't know
that you need to build like the biggest
playground
made out of soft area things and learn
about
mindfulness for your kids and stuff like
that you just
have a life of lived experiences which
is quite vast and you're a mindful guy
that's self-reflective and quite
truthful
so i think you have a strong foundation
for it but obviously
like you have none of the skills so do
you just start reading books when you
find out that your wife's pregnant what
what happens
so
we have she has uh so basically we start
going to um
birthing classes and it's it's a three
hour i want to say it's a three hour
class once a week for eight weeks
and we're in that class and that was
pretty incredible because it would be
three i
couldn't remember the last time i spent
three hours of
uninterrupted time with my wife right
we're just in the class sitting in a
chair with our arms around each other
and they have you practice doing all
sorts of stuff that i wasn't comfortable
doing like whispering affirmations into
her ear and just all
all this stuff right and and that but at
the end of every three hours i was like
stoked
it was it felt like it like i felt
closer to my wife from that and even
though
it is and so when we let me go back a
little bit so when we went into that
class our plan was to go to the hospital
and have the baby right
i wanted the safest best medical
treatment possible
and then about halfway through the class
the instructor said hey you don't want
to do a
a medical birth you don't want to do a
birth in a hospital i'm like yeah i do
and she goes no you don't and i go how
do you know
because i listen to the way you talk and
i can tell you do not want a hospital
birth
so i disregarded what the teacher said
but then finally one day when we were
visiting
what it's called an ob gyn my wife's ob
gyn i said
a couple things to her i said hey are
you gonna be at the birth and she
snapped back at me
what do you think i worked 24 hours a
day seven days a week and i was like
whoa whoa easy
and then i asked her something else i
can't remember and she pushed back and
got really angry
and then also told me that though that
this birth is going to be a partnership
and i'm like she's lying to me
or she has a total different view of
what a partnership is
so we started looking at um the home
birth route and we had avi at home
a home birth just in the living room of
our house
this is to answer your question so the
midwives leave
and then there's this dude it's just me
and my wife and this new dude
in the house you know and
you're pretty high you don't sleep for
like a couple days you're like
you're sky high like someone put cocaine
in your coffee every morning i mean you
are just out of your mind high
and fortunately she just started
breastfeeding him and i just kind of
just hung out and made sure i took care
of my wife i just faked it i guess
i i don't know how i knew what to do but
i just faked it just make sure there was
plenty of food for her and she just
basically sat around and breastfed him
on demand
for the first two or three months then
she started getting out of the house
i know a lot of women get out of the
house sooner than that but she's she
hung tight in the nest
and i uh yes
for the woman to hang tight yes i think
when i hear
i mean and who the hell am i i'm just
some dude but when i hear women already
going out for walks and stuff after a
week i do not think that's smart
i think that there's very few times that
human beings should stay
still and that is one of the times the
woman's body has just been through a
tremendous amount
and it's a time to for the woman to
reflect and
really really focus on herself and focus
on her baby
and the fact that they the the term i
hear a lot is they go stir crazy that
they need to get up and move or they
need to get out or they need a little
cup of coffee or they need a little bit
of wine or
like you know i'm not judging those
people don't get me wrong but i do have
really strong opinions on it i'm really
glad my wife didn't drink coffee leading
up to the pregnancy i'm really glad she
didn't
drink wine i'm glad she really stayed
still and took care of her body
if a woman does get up too early and
start moving around and be active she'll
start bleeding again
um it's a tremendous it's a tremendous
toll on the body i think to produce all
of that milk
you want the body to heal um
literally when she so she breast fed avi
for 18 months
while the twins were in her growing then
a month before the twins came out
she stopped breastfeeding and then the
twins came out
and then she stayed in the house for
another three months
imagine that like i bought it my very
first car i ever bought was a van my
wife and i bought a brand new van and
when i pulled it up to the house that
was the first time it was like the kids
were like two and a half three months
old to twins that was the first time she
came from the back room
and and looked outside oh i got a new
car and this is my wife who's
very active who did crossfit throughout
her entire pregnancy
you know the woman has abs she has she's
she's a beast
and um yeah the healing and maybe she's
also
the twins came when she was 42
right and we had those at home also
which is illegal in the state of
california
and isn't that amazing because women i
guess
aren't allowed to do what they want in
the united united states of america
is it the fact it was twins yeah
so you can't you can have one but you
can't have two
yeah can you have three i i don't know
it's anything over one so one one and a
half
that they're also a very fair question
i'm go i can only make the assumption
that three is also illegal
wow so you've got illicits do your your
children were
brought into this world smuggled into
this world
under the cover of of darkness
and and when you and when you have kids
at home
they don't get like when you have in the
hospital i can't i don't know exactly
how it happens but i think they get a
social security number and they get
their name
stamped and stoned in the heavens and
they become official americans right
when you have them at home that doesn't
happen so you have to take them to some
office and it it's a uh
at least in the city of berkeley
california it was a pretty
low rent vile endeavor um
just the lines you had to stand in and
the places you had to go
one or two newborn children yeah
yeah well i know i'm the um i'm on mike
kazu's podcast next week and obviously
him and indeed just had their little one
earlier this year and um i know that
mike has
him in the d classic like growth mindset
people who are used to consuming a lot
of
content in any case they just read
everything under the sun about birth and
babies and
and raising babies and they were i was
talking to him
earlier this year and he was adamant
about a home birth
absolutely adamant about it and he had
this big laundry list of reasons as to
why he had so
that's two for two on people that i
respect with regards to
child rearing saying that that is a
route that they took
the second the baby came out i knew
exactly why we did a home burst
because i could
not imagine moving my wife and that baby
at all i couldn't imagine there being
tubes in them
i couldn't imagine someone pricking
their feet i couldn't imagine putting
that precious baby in a baby seat and
then putting it into a car
i couldn't imagine like we were in our
nest
it's literally like that you have the
baby and you're in
your nest now i don't want to upset
anyone if you had the baby in the
hospital you had a great experience
kudos to you i'm not suggesting this i'm
telling you my experience
i could not imagine leaving i couldn't
imagine what letting anyone want to
touch my baby
i mean i was just um it was perfect i
knew right away
wow we're in the nest it would be crazy
to take the baby out of the nest
it's just like you're not supposed to
take a baby bird out of the nest right
yeah okay so we've we've got ourselves
to the birth now but you still
other than these three-hour sessions
where you
whisper nice things to your wife and
hugger i'm still not hearing
you assimilating some amount of
information which permits
you to do progressive things as a parent
what where's when does this start other
than other than taking time away from
the dog
so when they
so because we crossfit because i know
struggle causes adaptation i knew right
away that tummy time was important even
though people told me not to put the
baby on the tummy
i started putting the baby on its tummy
and the baby would scream and cry
and that would re that was really hard
because you intuitively just want to go
over and grab the baby so i started
setting a timer for like 30 seconds
and i would be like hey man it's only 30
seconds and i put the baby on its tummy
for 30 seconds
excuse me um then i get pick it up
then i do it to a minute then i do it to
three minutes then i start noticing the
baby's comfortable on its stomach
then it i i think i posted a video where
avi was two weeks old and he
and he rolled over that's pretty unheard
of for a baby right
then i would also see people who never
put their babies down
and their babies didn't crawl now i know
that's anecdotal
i don't have any proof of that but
everything that i don't listen to it
doesn't matter
every everything every time i saw
someone not put their baby down and it's
hard putting your baby down man
here's something you'll love chris this
is gonna be you when you're a dad
i never used a carrier and i hated to
use the stroller unless the baby was
sleeping
so i would carry the baby everywhere
because there i
figured either i need to be getting
strong or the baby needs to be getting
strong
so when i got tired of holding the baby
i would just set it on the ground coffee
shop floor
set them on the ground you know and then
just and then just stand over them
just ready to just destroy anything they
got gets near him you know
all foot five foot 550 pounds of me
and um
that and so i knew right away that um
you should you should you should cause a
little you should cause controlled
struggle in the baby's life you should
give him
and and i've seen babies in a hundred
different countries how they're raised
i spent a lot of time in africa i've
probably made ten trips to africa and
spent
i don't know four or five six months of
my life there throughout all those trips
uh those men who
i i've seen in africa in like in in the
really rural parts of africa are made of
[ __ ] steel
and are strong as i mean they're freaks
of nature
and their lives are hard
like i saw i saw i saw you know
one-year-old babies just
sitting or standing around in the fields
while the moms were you know trying to
get water
or hoe the fields i'm going to close
this window so the dog doesn't bark cool
excuse me so so i knew i knew early on i
i
have to give great glasses crossfit
methodology
like probably
you know and high inside 100 credit but
now that i'm my own man it's all me
but i'm going to have to give yeah it's
like it's that crossfit l1 man i can't
stop talking
about it it's um it's where i learned
about
how human beings operate it's operating
manual for the human human genome if you
want to know how to best
operate or treat a human being then you
have to take that l1 and i'll even go as
far as to say
that if you have kids and you don't take
the l1 i think that you're
um borderline being neglecting your
duties
what is the l1 what's the elevator pitch
that that's
so sorry so the l1 it's basically it's a
two-day course crossfit offers
it nicole carroll runs the program it
used to be nicole and carol and dave
castro it's basically all of greg
glassman's teachings
and the modifications nicole and dave
and the
amazing seminar staff have made to it
over the years
and it basically teaches you um how to
eat and how to move
and there's nothing there i think these
are greg's words that greg invented
these are just
movements that um god created like like
sitting on it like
squatting down and taking a dump and
being able to wipe your own butt
and if you take it to the extreme you
end up with someone like matt fraser
and if you use it to raise a baby you'll
end up like with avi joseph
and ari my three sons and basically
constantly varied always changing
movements that are
natural you know like squatting um and
as you become better at them ratchet up
the intensity make it harder and when
the bodies put in discomfort
that sucker adapts right i also
on the psychological side i never
my parents didn't push me
they did not push me and when they did
push me they didn't follow through and i
have great parents
my parents are awesome and super
supportive but i know
that i had crazy capacity as a kid and i
spent most of it riding my bike around
the neighborhood throwing rocks and
chasing girls
and i just feel like um i wish i danced
better and i wish i could kick ass
better so those are a couple of things
i'm making sure my boy can do he takes
ballet he just started tap
and um he takes martial arts
you know started it three days a week
when he was four and my twins at three
and now they're at five and six days a
week
so um so the principle that
you said there's two key underlying
principles one of them being
progressive overload essentially um
that you get them to do a thing and then
over time you increase the exposure
to that thing you also allow for
variation in that
and the second one was i guess what
corey allen would call the mindfulness
gap
observing their mind allowing them to to
notice their emotions and let it pass
and the same for yourself is that is
that that's the
the sort of two foundational principles
yeah yeah are we done yeah that's it
game over thank you
see you next time um so let me give you
these dudes
i wrote this down just in case you
structure discipline follow-through love
and boundaries those are i wrote those
down those are like
five five principles i talk about a lot
and then you can't let your kids hold
you hostage
you can dig into any of those um but yes
those first two things that you say
basically put them through
an uh controlled struggle since life is
pretty easy here in the united states
and then yes
be you have to make space so that um
when you put them on their tummy is that
dog barking too loud
uh it might be best if you can knock it
off and i'll i'll just pause this for a
second
i've made up a lot of reasons to take a
break on podcast but it's always because
i have to go to the bathroom this is i
think the first honest
you've actually done done a proper break
okay so
um yes gotta make space let's let's go
through your
five principles that you've written down
there then let's just go from the top
okay so they
they want to please you and they want to
be safe
kids want to please their parents and
they want to be safe
and so you have to figure out how you're
going to do that what are you going to
have them do
you know to get your attention and how
are you going to make it safe
and um
i did i don't know to go back to your
previous question i don't know how
i don't remember how i know that but i
just
maybe maybe i observed it or maybe
someone told me i wish i could give
someone credit for it but i know that
i know he really really really wants to
please me and i know that he
really really wants to he flourishes
when he's safe
how do you make it safe you have to have
crazy boundaries for your kid
and the boundaries you set they don't
even need to be
they don't even need to be legitimate
boundaries by legitimate i mean you
don't even have to justify them so let
me tell you one of the boundaries i have
my kid is never to touch my cell phone
ever ever ever ever ever it's easy you
just don't touch myself
oh i don't let you watch movies on my
cell phone you don't watch cartoons on
my cell phone you don't hold my cell
phone that's my cell phone
it's a boundary and i follow through by
never ever ever breaking it
now what's my kid know about me you you
would think from the outside that
they're learning hey they're not getting
your cell phone
right that they're learning so much more
than that they're seeing that i'm in
control
when they see that i'm in control guess
what they get
freedom so much freedom
i'm in control i'm sitting at the top of
the hill as the big lion
looking out over the savannah and they
can play freely
because i'm in control and how do they
know i have control because i have
boundaries there's no toys allowed in
this room behind me
there's no exceptions there's no i'm
sick there's no oh this is a stuffed
animal
this room doesn't have toys kids can
only come in here with the clothes on
their back
so another boundary do they try to bake
to break the boundaries yes
you have to enforce them you have to
follow through and all of those
within each of those so there's
boundaries i have to follow through
i can't be three kombuchas deep and be
like yeah go ahead
go ahead you can come in i'm drunk
tonight no that you that's
you're not doing your job hey that's not
how i'm painting my sistine chapel chris
right
i'm doing my sistine chapel when i'm
mixing my paints
i don't get lazy i'm not painting when
i'm drunk
um you know the days of popping an
oxycotin
and drinking two beers and watching a
movie with my wife those i don't do that
you know that that's 33. that's not
48 with three kids do you find it do you
find it easier
to be disciplined with your children
than with yourself
you're asking me at a really really
weird time because i'm so hyper
disciplined with myself right now
i'm so disciplined with myself right now
and by that i mean
i i i'm not drinking i haven't had any
refined because of covid i i believe
that you're completely inoculated from
covet if you don't eat any refined
carbohydrates or sugars
and so like i've made myself bomb proof
you know what i mean
i have not that the only carbohydrates i
have are leafy greens
um and meat that's all i eat and um so
you know what i mean i'm on i'm in
ketosis
so it seems to me it seems to me that
what you're talking about here doesn't
just require discipline
it's discipline being taught to your
children but the starting point the
inertia that you need to get over in the
first place is yourself as a parent
that if you aren't disciplined if you
are undisciplined as a parent
there is no hard boundary
for the child's discipline to come up
against you mentioned there
you you can create boundaries but
inevitably those boundaries
are going to be subject to your own
desire to be disciplined
so for instance one night parent ex
is feeling a little bit down and really
wants the comfort
of cuddles off her his or her child so
let them come into the living room with
their toys in their blanket because of
this thing
that requires discipline first the
foundation of the discipline is
built upon the parent and then broadcast
to the child yeah you know why i'm
having trouble
i think what you're saying is true and
why i'm having trouble understanding it
and to give another
explanation is i don't have to worry
about giving my kid oreos because i
would never allow oreos in my house in
the first place
and that that's actually not true i've
had guests who bring their kids over to
my house
and their guests don't like the shitty
desserts my wife makes without sugar in
them
so they bring their own desserts and
they their kids eat oreos in front of my
kids
now listen that doesn't mean you're not
flexible i have an
absolutely no tv
time or screen time when the sun is out
and tv is
only for friday nights and saturday
nights for the kids or for yourself
for the kids but
yeah for the kids and i don't watch tv i
only watch the ufc
um on saturday nights but um
but but but i have but but you do have
to be flexible and what do i mean by
that there there
there's um
a handful of times i've had a kid who's
really really sick you know just like a
fever and just shitty
and i've let him watch tv um when i take
my kids to jujitsu
and it's a two it's a two hour window
the kids class goes first and then the
older kids class goes
in that two-hour window i'll let the
kids
who are waiting watch a little bit of
ipad not the whole hour
i'll tell them hey watch your brother
compete for a little while or wrestle or
practice for a while
and then halfway through you can watch
the ipad so i don't want to sound like
there's not a place for it there are
things that there aren't a place for
chewing gum you should never give your
kid chewing gum
why you're being in a bad you're being a
bad parent there's no point to it
you're only hurting your kid why are you
giving a six-year-old chewing gum
what is that very common
oh buddy
oh buddy buddy buddy buddy so common
i see kids chewing gum all the time i
see kids at jiu jitsu and the instructor
has to tell them
spit the gum out now here i'm going to
tell you why parents give their kids
chewing gum
this is not probably this would have
never resonated with me
before i had kids but there's something
called the hostage situation
parents are always 100
of their waking hours and even in their
sleeping hours probably
preparing for the hostage situation and
waiting for impact and what that means
is you ask me chris can i have some gum
heidi heidi means dad and armenian
and i say and i want to say no i know
it's the right answer
but i'm in line at starbucks and i'm
next and if i say no you might have a
temper tantrum and i might not get my
coffee
because i have to carry you outside and
then i say yes you can have a piece of
gum
it's where all the bad decisions are
made in the hostage situation
and it's crazy there's hostage
situations everywhere every time your
kid
opens his mouth you're in a hostage
situation and they
they're constantly asking for stuff but
you have to follow through and you have
to have these boundaries
if you don't every time you give in you
will be doing two things
you'll be [ __ ] on your sistine
chapel meaning hurting your kid
and you'll be weakening your position
for the next time
but you'll also be making your kid feel
unsafe
if there's no wind there's no wind
that was the sixth uh principle right
you had your five and then kind of
was the the hostage don't let yourself
be held hostage was number six is that
correct
yeah i guess i am flopping around what
did you say you're not gonna come on my
podcast
flop around that's what i'm here for i'm
here to flip flop around
um number one what was number one
um they're struck kids need structure
yep
daily routine yes and even even i appl i
do structure even through their clothing
so i just i make life so easy for my
kids my kids wear the same thing every
single day basically
they have a they have these these pants
that they wear and they have a
uh what we call a wife beater in the
united states it's like a just a white
tank top
and i know it could use a better name
right
and then and then sweaters they have a
long sleeve sweater and a short sleeve
sweater
and they can depending on how cold or
hot it is they can layer up or layer
down and then the shoes are always in
their car because there's no need for
shoes at home why would you have shoes
at home
well you got to walk to the carpet yeah
you just go barefoot
that's the advantage that it's coming
from a man who lives in very temperate
climate
true true um then the second thing after
structure is discipline
and not discipline in the fact that they
need discipline like
i guess it's a cousin of structure not
discipline like hey they need spankings
but they just need to have things
that are organized they need to
understand that okay
every monday wednesday friday i'm going
to do this at 3 o'clock no question
asked i know it sounds like structure
but it's also disciplined because
they're kids and they're not gonna wanna
do it
so they have to they have to start
building habits of discipline
uh love and attention that one i don't
ma'am so i had really loving parents
and my parents couldn't keep their hands
off me and my uncles and aunts couldn't
keep their hands off me i was always on
someone's shoulder someone always had
their hand up the back of my shirt
someone was always pinching my cheeks
someone was always holding me upside
down i mean i
i don't know how um
i don't i don't know i don't know that
one's so innate in me i don't know how
you would teach that
i don't know how you would you would
work on that other than maybe to just
love yourself more
but you can see love and detention
attention requires time
and if you have someone who hasn't
perhaps turned the corner
that you and your wife have and another
thing to consider is that because you
guys are
further through your careers and have
lived more life
perhaps some of the open loops oh i
would have unfulfilled dream x i would
have this
particular dream why um those things are
now closed
also by the sounds of things chasing
materialistic goals for you is quite low
down the list of priorities especially
in comparison to your kids now and with
that being a fact as well like
there's no reason to go to work you know
you've got the the classic
ceo of a fortune 500 company
you know working in the the the matron
or the
au pair or whoever they've got comes
around and looks after the kids and then
he
gives it a tap on the head at night and
then goes to bed and wakes up three
hours later and goes back to the office
or flies off
to japan to do a deal whatever it might
be like
that's a way that would very quickly get
in the way of attention right you can't
give love and attention if you're not
there if you're not present
and presence is both right physical
presence and then mental presence let's
say that
you do decide to take the one week off
with the family but
big dick exec ceo man his thoughts his
brain's still in the office he's still
thinking about the emails he needs to
reply to when he's supposed to be
watching his kids jump in the pool
right you nailed it at the most basic
level you have to be there physically
hey you just brought up number six i
might write a book after this podcast
you should do
numbers number six relationship
my relationship did you just go from
number three to number six i did bear
with me
you are yours number six number six the
relationship
my relationship with my wife is vital
because of
on the most basic level every child
wants one every i can say this about
every single child every child wants a
mom and dad that love each other
they just want that i wanted it you
wanted it
everyone wanted it my parents divorced
it's okay it's fine
but but you don't get everything you
want in life but i wanted it
i it doesn't mean my wife and i don't
fight in front of our kids we have
definitely fought in front of our kids
and do you make uh do you make a point
of trying not to do that
uh yeah absolutely before we had kids i
would i was much more aggressive in
getting the last word
now from the second to start fights i'm
trying to shut the [ __ ] up
i'll take her in the back room and and
and
and we can [ __ ] fight it out there
but i try to just
shut the [ __ ] up i do not want to see my
kids ever be rude to my wife
and they have but
so sorry just just to just to interject
that what you're suggesting is that
your kids will mirror the way that you
operate and if they see you
being rude to their mum
they may also enact that behavior is
that the concern you have
yeah all of those things and i never
want to see my kids lose
i don't like want my kids to see me lose
control
losing control is the worst way to
handle a situation 99
of the time and so i don't want them to
see me lose control my wife and i need
to fight
not a lot but we need to fight we got
some you know we just need to fight
sometimes
and um and maybe someday we won't need
to but like
before we had kids almost all of our
reasons for fighting were gone we almost
never fought then we have kids and now
there's some more reasons to fight again
but i don't want them to see me lose
control you're right and i do see you
nailed it i do see them mirror my
behavior i see them
when they when they fight with each
other which is very rare
they um physically they fight non-stop
but i mean like
uh intellectually and emotionally they
don't fight and when they do they they
it's my wife and i they take turns
playing us they don't i don't think they
know it but yeah
totally you nailed it um but i always
i try not to fight in front of my kids
but i'm not perfect
but where i am perfect in which everyone
can be perfect is i
always make up with my wife in front of
my kids
even if i'm not [ __ ] ready i will
fake that [ __ ] and make it fake it till
i make it
i want my kids to see that it's okay to
be humble
and that happiness and peace are so much
better than fighting
and that it's okay to apologize and get
over the hump and we can circle back
around and finish the fight later or
talk later
but i i and it makes them feel secure
and it gives them you know it offers a
lot to the household but i
always want to make up because if i
don't then it's about me
but it's not about me it's about them
it's about
like have your kids made you a better
husband
yeah for sure yeah yeah yeah for sure
for sure for sure for sure for sure oh
100
better um
i am i'm already a loyal person
i'm a very loyal person um i can take a
lot of abuse
from once i'm locked in with someone i
can take a lot of abuse and still be
loyal but
i'm even more fiercely loyal
to her maybe you know if i would
um support her in her endeavors
because she's painting her sistine
chapel too right we're working on the
same canvas
and so i want to give her i'm i don't
want to do anything to disturb her while
she's painting
right i don't want to do any ripples
that will cause her to be a lesser
mom than she needs to be
and so i get that i get that and that
makes sense but
that to me appears to have the
locus of love be the children rather
than each other now i appreciate that
you guys are still a team
but how many couples do we see that have
kids and the stress of having the kids
doesn't bind them together but it pushes
them apart
and you have couples who've been
together and then
johnny's two years old or alice is one
and a half years old
and the relationship breaks down
so i'm trying to i'm trying to delve
into
the relationship between you and her not
in service of the kids
you know so we
that's a good question and maybe i've
lost sight of that i need to think about
that but
we were together for so long so we met
as college kids right
and we partied in the same circle and i
courted her for five years and i knew
her boyfriend and she knew my girlfriend
and um then we got together and then we
were together for 15 years and we
traveled the world together for work and
then we work together
and you know what's interesting chris i
i forgot about this but i was
i was living in in a pickup truck and i
was sitting in the back of a pickup
truck in isla vista california it's a
beach town college town and i was laying
there just with my shorts on and shirt
off just waiting for it to warm up so i
could go to the beach and i was reading
the dow to ching
and i see her walking down the street
towards me
and i'm like oh man i'm going to talk to
this chick and you know see if she'll
come to the beach with me i mean that's
the kind of town it was right
and i had seen her around before so i
jump out of the back of my truck she's
like what are you reading what are you
reading
and we start talking and she's also into
lao tzu and the daoda ching
and from that
moment and we've talked extensively
about it over the 20 years when we talk
about it regularly we knew
that we were both personally responsible
for our happiness
and when you're in a relationship with
someone like that
eventually at the end of the day you can
throw all of your fights and problems
kind of
into that light
and it will shed a ton of light on it
because each person is like personally
responsible the blame game really goes
away
and so i'd say like 95 of the problems
go away so
just quickly off the top of my head i i
believe that's the foundation of our
relationship and i believe that's why
we've um
done so well um of course
who knows what will happen maybe in 15
years or 20 years when the kids move out
we'll get a divorce that's a whole
that's a whole nother boundary for
people to get over man
that really is like yeah i hear i hear
you i just can't even imagine that
my brain my brain as you asked me that
my brain just like
there's no [ __ ] way like like like
you it it's also this
um have you ever had a friend who you
played a sport with and like you guys
are best friends and you do it seven
days a week you just
every single day you're doing it you're
doing it and then one of you drifts off
and doesn't do that sport anymore
and so your friendship just takes its
natural progression and it just
it just wanes it's not you're they're
still best friends but now you only see
them once a year instead of
with them 12 hours a day so
i don't know what the glue is but
something's kept us together
um whether it be life um
these kids but um right now we're closer
than ever i mean we just
we just we just work these kids that's
awesome man okay so
we've got one two and three done
structure discipline follow through
follow through
and and we sort of touched on the follow
through too because that's part of sort
of number
oh man maybe there's seven um follow
follow through
is if you say something you have to do
it
and i i screwed this up in the beginning
a lot because i would lay down
disciplines that i wasn't really willing
to follow through with so if your kid
if friday is movie night and friday
morning your kid does something to piss
you off
don't say hey if you do that one more
time i'm not going to give you movie
night
because that's a long [ __ ] 10 hours
for your kid to work on you and change
your mind
do you know what i mean so he throws
something at the at the breakfast table
you tell him not to if he does it again
you're going to take away movie night he
throws it again
and you take away a movie night now you
have 10 hours
and another thing my wife taught me so
my wife taught me that hey make sure
that you're able to follow through
and the other thing is the
follow-through ideally
and should be connected to the
the consequence should be ideally
connected to
the crime so you're not necessarily you
take away
moving night but then maybe it's more
like okay that's the second time you've
thrown it you're dismissed from the
table you can eat again at lunch
i don't know and you just make them stop
eating breakfast or something like that
but you have once you make threats you
better follow through
if you don't there is no homeostasis
it's not like okay that's a wash you're
either getting
making better kids and being a better
parent or you're making worse kids and
being a worse parent
there's no like okay we're just happily
in the middle it's
never ever ever like that
and so um
the the follow-through is key because if
you don't you're going to
you're going the opposite direction
you're making worse kids and
so you have to be really careful what
comes out of your mouth
and that includes like hey i'm tonight
when i come home from work i'm going to
make legos with you for 30 minutes you
got to do it
you got to do it you want there to be
and then all of those other things will
get bolstered too you're showing
structure you're showing your discipline
you're showing your boundaries it's all
of that if you can't do it
if your kid asks you hey will you make
legos with me tonight but you're afraid
to say no because you know he's going to
scream
and you so you say yes anyway and then
don't do it you're screwing up two of
the two of
my premises you've now been held in a
hostage situation and now you're not
doing follow-through
how can how can parents say no more
productively
don't don't lie to your kid don't
sugarcoat it don't
don't don't don't fool around in the
long run all that stuff will just bite
you in the ass
if you can't if you can't tell the truth
don't say anything take a few deep
breaths
you know let's say your kid's in the
back seat and you're driving
them home from class and they say mommy
can i
stop at mcdonald's and you know when you
say no they're going to start screaming
in the back and you don't want to hear
it
fine take a few deep breaths and then
say no and brace yourself you'd be
surprised how often they
don't scream once they respect you
that you're no means no
i would say 95 of the times kids scream
for more than 20 seconds
it's because they know that there's a
crack
in the dam they know that you might give
in
once you're consistent with nose and you
give it to the kid straight every time
you you'll see that go away you'll
really really see that go away i mean
literally
people are blown away the fact that i
can just walk right by an ice cream shop
both kids outside eating
and my kids won't you know at most maybe
one out of ten times they'll say can we
have an ice cream i go no we don't need
ice cream here you know that
and that's it that's it one of the
things that was playing through my mind
as you talked about your ideas sorry
sorry
sorry to answer your question it's never
easy saying no okay sorry
i imagine i imagine that um
the pulling on the heartstrings like
especially i'm like quite an emotional
person naturally i'm quite empathetic
uh you know i i fear the the size of
love that i'm gonna have for whatever
humans that i do bring into this world
uh and i imagine that it is quite hard
to say no
on a number of levels that you want your
kid to be happy you want your kid to
love you
all of the self-esteem issues that
you've got about wanting to be liked and
wanting to be loved by your kid will
also still be in there as well because
of how you were treated at school or how
you were treated by your parents
and then you don't want to deal with the
headache of them screaming and you don't
want the public
outcry when people look at you as that
parent with that screaming child and
stuff
so i imagine that saying no is is a
challenge especially if you can't say no
to yourself
if you're the person that says i'm gonna
quit drinking
once every six months and never follows
through with it
i put this in my newsletter not long ago
that having faith
in your own word is one of the most
important things that you can do
you need to treat yourself like somebody
you are responsible for helping it's a
jordan petersonism
and if you don't have trust that what
you say you're going to do
after a while just like the friend that
keeps on never showing up when you
invite them for coffee you're just not
going to invite them anymore or maybe
you're even going to hate them
so you very much need to treat yourself
like a friend and
if you are going to bring kids into this
world
you really need to sort your own [ __ ]
first if you don't have self-discipline
if you don't have structure if you don't
have a growth mindset if you're not able
to
let things pass like all that you're
going to do is further ingrain that into
your children
i think we very much need to see the
um how do you say the heritage
the the genealogy of your habits your
routines being taken into your children
and this is what was making me think
when you're talking about the set of
scales about your either becoming a
better parent or you're becoming a worse
parent and that goes along with better
kids or worse kids
um there's a quote from
ethan suplee the guy from remember the
titans and wolf of wall street huge huge
like massive 500 pound guy who's now 230
and jacked
like eight percent body fat he came on
the show he had a martial arts
instructor
who used the the saying no bad reps
and what no bad reps means is that
you're always drilling something
every action that you do and this
relates to neurologically how we lay
down myelin
in sheaths in our brain you are always
creating
a habit you don't have the choice of not
creating a habit
it's a decision between one particular
habit and another type of habit there is
no no habit
there is only this that or the other
habit and
very much so with the kids it it very
harks to hard choices easy life easy
choices
hard life and there isn't a okay choice
okay life
there isn't there isn't one of those
it's always going to be a decision
between what's right
and what necessarily isn't
perfect perfectly said going back to
that very first thought about
you're gonna want it's gonna be hard to
say no because you want them to love you
and that is the that is the at the end
of the day
the equation that will get you the most
love
is to have really really strong
boundaries with your kids
really really strong boundaries see that
seems
counterintuitive i'll tell you why
the the more boundaries they are the
safer they'll
they will feel the safer they feel the
closer they'll come to you
and so
i i wanna like so so so and boundaries
are very
boundaries are very simple um so so let
me
let me show you the balance i have this
room behind me that i tell you kids are
not allowed in with toys
i have another room that's just their
room
and it's a free for all
the toys in the world so there's balance
there but
once you start setting boundaries with
your kid and they start respecting you
they which should be just right away and
your only metric will be to compare them
to other kids unfortunately
you'll see that your kids are so much
better behaved
they're so much more willing to listen
to you they're so much more willing to
talk to you and be open to you they're
just going to feel
safe if you just say yes to everything
that
they're just you're going to have spin
outs you're not but it's going to be
worse than that i got i haven't thought
about this in a long time i used to
really think about this a lot when i was
really getting comfortable because it is
it is something you have to get
comfortable with to build boundaries for
your kids
what will happen is if you don't build
boundaries for your kids is you'll end
up having kids that nobody likes
so let me give you an example you're on
your phone talking you and i are talking
and you have a kid let's say chris you
have a son
and he keeps asking you questions about
our conversation and you keep answering
them telling them what we're talking
about
instead of hey chris junior i'm on the
phone
you need to go step away and give me
space
that's what you have to say it's your
time with your friend
savon we're talking if you don't do that
now you're teaching a kid hey it's okay
and i don't know if you have friends who
have kids but this is a big problem with
kids
the pa the kids are just allowed to
interrupt they have no boundaries
their parents let them hold their cell
phones they let them talk to them when
they're on the phone
they interject in conversations if they
want to be a part of mine in your
conversation and
be adults then they have to act like
adults hey chris is talking
wait till he's done yeah i mean you know
what i mean i've heard you do this we've
been on the phone and i've heard you do
this
you know your kids have been we continue
to have conversations while you're at
the skate park
and inevitably skate park
children floor like it's you know
you don't need to be a genius to work
out what's going to go on there and you
can hear in the background
[Music]
i'm like well i'm thinking on the phone
i'm thinking on the phone
do you need to go like and i'm waiting
to hear
in your voice the um the anxiety the
anticipation i'm waiting to hear the
discomfort arise and it doesn't and i
don't know whether you're walking over
to him or he's coming over to you or
whatever it might be
but what a couple of times you said hey
sweetie
i'm on the phone so you can come here
and lick your wounds but if you do i
need you to be quiet okay
that was it and it took 15 seconds
for whichever of the three children that
was
to be just sniffly
that i could barely hear him that's just
sloppy parenting on my part
um taking him to the skate park and
scheduling a phone call with
the williams what are you talking about
okay
uh it's funny i i i hear parents say
that all the time about how you should
multitask
and um i have a few friends that when
they call me
like i'll always answer even if i'm like
[ __ ]
you know neck deep and [ __ ] but uh yeah
it's um you you if you
if you have boundaries your kids will
love you more the more you say no to
them
the more they'll love you i know that's
a little gross exaggeration and not a
perfect equation
but your kids have to feel safe around
you and
and they're they are going to look back
when they're older and they're going to
see all the things that you did to them
that didn't help them
they're going to say like i never let my
parents live it down oh my god you took
me to mcdonald's three days a week i
can't believe it and i was seven years
old you let me order the 20 piece with
seven hot mustards what was wrong with
you you know what i mean like
um it doesn't mean your kids don't get
free time it doesn't mean that they
don't get to rage there just have to be
certain boundaries
and they have to be logical boundaries
and
uh and you'd be super you'd be surprised
um if you're a short-term gra if you're
a quick short-term gratification guy
yeah then saying no is gonna be hard but
i can tell by looking at your physique
and your dedication to this podcast and
your business that like you're not a
short-term gratification guy
it's gonna come very very naturally for
you i know
i hope that it working i hope that it
will
but i also know i see firsthand we're
all our worst
critics right so we all see our own sort
of failings up close and personal
and on top of that i also know that
even as what i would consider hopelessly
undisciplined
i'm still wildly more disciplined than
most of the people that i know
um which you know it's that that old
saying where they say think about how
stupid the average person is and realize
that half p
half of the people are more stupid than
that um if you think about how
undisciplined the average person is
and then realize that 50 of people are
less disciplined than that person
like that's quite scary um and again it
kind of goes
back to what i was saying earlier on
about the
heritage that your children are going to
get is very much a
microcosm of what you are we see this
even in businesses
you know you see coming out the crossfit
world like
think about the internal company culture
that you get with an owner like greg
glassman and a
games director like dave castro you see
that
you see that even if people perhaps
didn't want that
to be the way that they acted forward we
my core industry of club promo i could
stand on the
on a street corner and look at the
different pr's that are going hey guys
where are you going tonight do you want
to come to our nightclub
and putting wristbands on people i could
stand on a street corner
and without seeing the badge that they
have that tells us their company
i could identify by their mannerisms and
by what they're wearing
that guy works for that company that guy
works for that company that get because
they're just little projections of the
guys that own it at the top
everybody knows this right and right
this is the same
in family life as it is in business life
as it is in
everything else right right
um you you want people to like your kids
you want people to like your club set
your
set set the culture up in your business
so that people like your business
and set your culture up at your home
with your kids so people like your kids
people love kids with boundaries
and and at the end of the day
the harsh reality of life at the end of
the day is
hard work and who you know and who likes
you
so those of you who are in high school
who are listening to this and you're
like oh i can't wait to get out of high
school and the popularity contest is
over i have really bad news for you
it's never over so
that's another jordan peterson-ism uh
never let your kids do anything that
makes you hate them
uh and that that very much so is the
case i think
sadly i think i was a very easily
unlikable kid
i was an only child wasn't massively
socialized
and it meant that i i didn't really
properly understand the boundaries of
sort of social cohesion and
and how to really act and and play with
other kids just
time and attention and i hadn't had a
lot of time knowing how to do it
um and yeah i totally totally get that
as well
thinking about some friends who are just
starting now as
teacher trainers you're three so seven
and eight year olds
and in the class the kids who are the
nicest ones that have the boundaries
that are the best behaved
they'll gravitate toward them because
they'll want to spend time with them
because they're cute and they say miss
miss can i do this thing you're
you smell nice or you're this and
they'll want to laugh and have an
interaction
and it very much is a winner takes all
environment
you know we talk about how um financial
privilege permits people to be in a
better position than others but we never
really talk about personality privilege
about the fact that being innately
likable which is drawn from being
extroverted slightly
rather than introverted the kid who's
over the far side doing weird things i
probably was
like naturally doesn't get as much of
your attention firstly because they're
out of sight and out of mind and
secondly because if you do go over and
spend time with them they're maybe a
little bit
you just don't get what what's going on
with them so much so
that really is a different form of
privilege that i've never thought about
until now but personality privilege
absolutely is a thing and the more that
you have these boundaries the more that
you can make your kids likeable to
other people you know if you understand
how compounding works if you can be
likable by the age of six
as opposed to by the age of 26 which is
like around about when it took me to do
it
um you are going to be so much further
ahead
because the jiu jitsu teacher is going
to be fine letting you stay an extra 10
minutes because he thinks that you're
cool
or the dance teacher doesn't mind about
you turning up without your shoes when
everyone else has to do this thing
because she knows that you're well
behaved and you wouldn't have left your
shoes if you didn't really mean it to be
that way
or whatever it might be so yeah i'm
massively on board with regards to the
make your kids likeable
yeah at four years old if your kid can
say thank you and please
there are leaps and bounds ahead of the
other kids and they will reap the
rewards for that in life
they'll reap the rewards for it right
away the kid who says thank you to their
teacher when they hand out snacks will
get the snack first the next day
all of that being said some of the
greatest people we know had the most
abusive
jacked up upbringings ever and that kind
of circles me back around to struggle
causes adaptation
and so since my kids don't have any of
bad [ __ ] happen in their life i have to
create it for them yes absolutely i have
to pour but i have to pour a cold bucket
of water on them at three in the morning
just to remind no no i'm joking
let david go after
i do have to uh we do have to create
that struggle for them
a close friend of mine um or who was a
close friend of mine i haven't talked to
him in a long time but russell berger
he gave a lot he gave like a 30-minute
speech
on the importance of putting your kids
through struggle
and it was fascinating i wonder if i can
i wonder if it was recorded
but he nailed it and that was before i
had kids maybe that had a huge impact on
me
i totally get what you mean there as
well that the amount of comfort
um that your children have
let's say that you do make your kids
quite likable
and an alright amount of extroverted the
amount that they need to get them over
the social
sort of line which everybody has to play
the social game or social species as
much as
some of us may not want to be um and
let's say that you do do all of those
things
without the struggle i think that your
kids would be regressing to the mean
and what i mean by that is that the more
ordinary your life the more ordinary
your communications are with everybody
else then the more ordinary your
outcomes are going to be
if you want extreme outcomes you also
need to have extreme inputs
and if you have this very
normal level of social cohesion and
communication
and even if it's extraordinary or in
terms of
its effectiveness it's still that what
you're aiming for with a lot of social
like they're not going to read stephen
covey or like the art of persuasion at
this stage
it's about just simply being able to be
personable
you do need something that's going to
set them apart or else what you're doing
is making someone who is
really really really good at being
normal
[Laughter]
that was great so what's next number one
you kind of
no you don't wait you know who you kind
of look like a little bit do you know do
you know the show ray donovan
no do you know lee shriver is
no no oh man you gotta look him up he's
amazing
you look like him it's it's it's it's a
compliment yeah check out that show
are you hitting on ray donovan you don't
have no not yet
okay until after the hangout yeah yeah
um no that would be just that would be
disrespectful to my wife that i would
have hit on you in the past but now that
i have kids
fun that's fine um
there was something there was something
you said that it slips me okay so
so love and attention boundaries um
that we talked about the hostage
situation we did we did them all
structure discipline follow through i
don't know if i did any of them good
you did structure discipline
follow-through
love and attention boundaries and in
love and attention
that that's really a time also for you
to work on yourself because
because loving someone is a lot of it is
just really staying still and creating
space for them
um boundaries um the
the hot hostage situation and then i
guess number ships
relationships yeah yeah what's the
what's the number one mistake or the
most common mistake that you see parents
making
putting bad [ __ ] into their kids bad
food
yep nutrition i can i can tell right
away
like um so my kids are wild but their
wildness is focused
it's focused they're throwing a [ __ ]
tennis ball at the wall
over and over and over right they grab
each other by the head and throw each
other down they swing from the tree
when i put a tiniest bit of sugar into
them that wildness is
almost like they start talking to
themselves they start doing like
tapping they get jittery they start like
um
instead of singing songs they they
babble even the slightest bit of sugar
starts to interfere with the
expression of the wildness it makes it
um yeah it makes it jittery it doesn't
make it clean it doesn't make it
poignant
i know it almost sounds like it's an
oxymoron to be controlled wildness but
it's a controlled wildness
it looks like chaos but man like he's
meaning to throw that ball a hundred
times at my wall until he tries to put a
hole in it
whereas if he wasn't doing that he might
also be screaming or throwing it up in
the air
and you see that in classes the most
common thing is
is you know in group settings so the
kids who
who have poor diet will usually have
poor focus i mean it's
it's um
it's it's pretty obvious i think it's
pretty obvious how do you
what are the rules what are the rules
that you feed your kids on so
so these are the things you want to try
absolutely no sugar
at all times if they do have to eat
sugar you feed them stuff like a banana
that's the sugar you give them you give
them natural sugars your kids should be
eating eggs
avocados chicken celery
carrots cucumbers spinach
um my wife kids are kids oatmeal
we get we give our kids peanut butter
i'm sure about somebody probably doesn't
like that
no no treats but they might have
something okay
so yeah yeah so sorry so a treat would
be a banana
a treat would be um so here's one of the
great advantages to having three kids if
i do give them something like a bar
like a lara bar or an rx bar
i i give them rx bars i can and there's
it's all just natural stuff in there
right it's like date smashed with nuts
i can cut it into three pieces
so if it's a 200 calorie bar you know
let's say and i don't know how many
grams of sugar let's just say nine
then when i cut it into three pieces
now i have a uh 67 to 66 calorie bar
right with only three grams of sugar and
sometimes you know when i'm smart i
always give the bigger piece to avi
because he's the older boy
so but i don't do treats like so avi did
got after two years of jiu jitsu three
days a week he got his gray belt
i bought him ice cream i bought all the
boys ice cream they got a treat
um he skateboarded a hundred days in a
row
and i didn't even tell him i was gonna
do this but i was marking the days
unbeknownst to him
and then on the hundredth day i took
them to the point and i said today's
oh awesome i didn't know that and i go
yeah and you get ice cream
so i do do treats like that i do do
surprises i want to reward him on the
highest level for achievements that are
like
that i believe are grandiose that i deem
grandiose right
um but in the end
i'm not doing it because i'm weak i'm
not doing it because i think
i'm soft or he'll love me more i'm doing
it because i think it'll make him
better i think it makes him a better
person knowing that there's a reward and
that he's being recognized for his good
deeds
you know it's not oh i'm just going to
get my kid ice cream because he was good
today
nah like i knew in advance
it's it's a plan
it's a plan i wanna i wanna make i wanna
make them the best
i think you and i joked about this a
little bit i wanna make them the best
mates possible
i want girls to like them and i want
boys to like
them and i want i want people to like
them and i want them to be able to live
up to that
um love that they receive from the world
we've talked a lot about gardener
we've talked a lot about um the sort of
the physical side you
get your kids to train they do sort of
complex physical movements
jumping on bars and balance beams and
bits and pieces like that
one thing that we haven't really touched
on is more the intellectual kind of
cognitive cerebral development
what have been some of the realizations
that you've got from that
so they so they do math and reading
every single day from the age of three
for anywhere between five and twenty
minutes
are you home schooled um avi supposed to
be uh avi is supposed to be in school
right now it's supposed to be a it's a
homeschool program
um even without following the curriculum
he's
above and beyond just because from such
a young age at three
we've been doing this five to twenty
minutes every single day
i just played chess with him for the
first time a couple days ago
i was inspired by something i saw on
instagram another a friend of mine who
has three sons who was playing
chess with his kids i do sight words
with them i do spelling with them and
then he has to read for 20 minutes every
day i guess i could do those things with
my son but i'm 48 and i don't want to
get injured and i'm like very like
careful not to get injured because i
push myself so hard all day with the
kids
so like people are like hey why aren't
you taking jiu jitsu it's because i
don't mind sitting on the sideline
and watching and then people will be
like well you'll get a better outcome if
you do it and maybe they're right
i don't know that but i have heard that
a lot that philosophy that you should be
doing the activities with your kids you
should be doing soccer you should be
doing wrestling you should be doing jiu
jitsu
but is it not does it not massively that
you just don't want your kid to be able
to beat you up
like there's going to become a point
where avi's going to be able to submit
you
if i just put out a limb he's like all
over me like if i just put my hand on
his head like and grab his head strong
he's all over me he's gonna be able to
beat me up when he's eight um
but um but what i really really
like about all of this instruction is my
son
sons are getting um personal
one-on-one interaction from professional
trainers they're learning their
vocabulary they're learning
all their different personalities
they're learning all their different
demeanors
i hear avi come home from tennis and
using words like you know volley and
love and just like
and then he comes home from striking
well i'm there and
and he's like hey check out my faint and
then he's a look at my parry and he's
like his vocabulary or when he goes to
dance he's like did you know plie means
bend and
you know um so i really
and i've said this before and i really
mean this first and foremost before
any of the physical activity i like just
the idea of them getting professional
training i love the idea of them
getting um
getting this interaction with other
adults one on one
he's really really manned up it's really
made him like a fun
social animal as a kid but he's still
wild and crazy like a kid you know it
hasn't taken any of the kid out of him
so for now i don't know what the long
term well the long term goal is
i would love for him to learn everything
there is to know about math take math to
the
far reaches of the you know calculus
trigonometry galaxy
and then english become a master of the
the english language um one of the
largest vocabularies of anyone i've ever
met was greg glassman
and it truly made him a magician because
when you have an enormous vocabulary
and you're comfortable juxtaposing any
words together that you deem
can be put together you then conduct
reality that's another dao
saying naming is the origin of all
particular things
and so i would love for him to be able
to diagram sentences and have a
complete handle on english and then a
complete handle on math
and the rest i could give two shits
about because
hopefully he'll grow up to be someone
like you chris who's like a reading
machine and he can teach himself
with the foundation i gave him very
complimentary man
the i was reading the navalmenac this
morning and
in that naval's prescription for anyone
in the 21st century the two skills that
they need to learn maths
and persuasion persuasion could be
probably supplemented for
english and his justification for that
is that maths forms the foundation for
pretty much everything that we do
if you can do maths then you understand
economics micro macro you understand
accounting you understand how to do
investments you understand the
first principles that physics works on
you understand how chemistry works
and then from persuasion it is the other
side of that it's everything else it's
the me and you
it's the um ability to
convince other people and you said there
that
your ability to deploy language um is
kind of directly proportional to your
ability to get on in life
and one of the reasons for that is that
fluency
and truthfulness are seen as the same
thing
this is how charlatans and con men get
passed because even though what they're
saying isn't truthful
the way that they're saying it is so
convincing and compelling because
they're able to have this beautiful flow
and all of the words are precise
and the cadence is correct and there's
no ums and ours there's no stutters
there's no nothing else
and the reason that they're able to get
past people is because of their delivery
so when fluency is truthfulness by
another name
having a good grasp of the english
language is important and having the
mathematics space
man you're going to have some world
beaters on your hands it's going to be
fascinating watching them grow up and i
i hope as well i think
i speak for everyone who follows you on
instagram um that
we all are kind of now invested in your
kids development and we want to see them
do very well
um which is you know that's a beautiful
thing like they're likeable
i'm presuming that you're not just
uploading the highlight reels and their
dicks outside of it
um but you know we see
we see the kids do that we see that
i am putting the real stuff on patreon
by the way okay
um yeah man you know i want to i want to
see them do well and i want to see you
guys do well and i think that
whatever it is that you're doing
whatever we want to call this 21st
century parenting enlightened parenting
awakened parenting
you know um whatever particular
terminology we do
i i think that it's like well well well
overdue and for me again as someone who
currently doesn't have kids doesn't have
anyone that i can have kids with
um but wants them it's inspiring
and it's very um it's very eye-opening
to see
such a such a familiar structure that
i'm used to the growth mindset
the um structured programming the
understanding of discipline the first
principles thinking
uh the boundaries all of that sort of
stuff that i utilize in other areas of
my life
to see that applied to what really is
for most of us the greatest thing that
we'll ever achieve which is bringing
other humans into this world and making
them as good as we can
um and to see that laid out in front of
me is really really really exciting
between you and
mike and ed casu i think i've got a a
couple of good
um how do you say role models to try and
live up to
thank you that's about the nicest thing
anyone said to me today
well it's only like 10 10 a.m your time
how much nice stuff has people said
for that to be a competition i got so
many i love yous this morning
oh god give
that that math um you said you connected
something else for me
that math actually ties so closely with
persuasion
because people who have a firm grasp on
math usually are very
logical and they don't let emotion
convolute their thinking which is a
huge problem in the united states right
now huge problem people are so emotional
that they can't think straight they are
so passionate on calling two plus two
five
because they're so emotional about it
when like when you're good at math
i think you're also less likely to make
those mistakes those logical mistakes
i saw a hat today james lindsay my buddy
who wrote he did the dog park grievance
studies thing where he conned
journals into believing that he was like
some feminist
scholar um and he uh he
has a website newdiscourses.com and he
posted he has merch on there
and this new merch that he just put up
today is like a
a maga looking hat like a red hat white
text
and it just says make two plus two equal
four again
i love it
just now you went and i thought i felt
spit
land on my lip is that weird no that's
kind of hot though like like i thought
like i thought you spit on me come on
man
no the honestly the the gay rumors on
the internet are absolutely abound
because they keep on saying that i'm
first trapping my way into big like to
get big guests on the show
and i'm like hang on a second if this
was a girl no one would bat an eye
like girls are perfectly allowed to
first trap their way through life
that's some feminine privilege for you
right there like that's that's where
as men are not permitted to do stuff
look dude this i i've absolutely adored
today and
i really want to try and get deeper into
the weeds about this and and maybe even
talk about sort of the physical pursuits
and how you're piecing those together
but i think we can probably afford to
leave it there for now um
i'm really fortunate to have met you man
i really uh again
to the people for whom they need another
example of why you should just dm people
and not be fearful of it
i just reached out to you as a random dm
because i saw i've been watching your
stuff for ages
and mercifully you got back to me and
now we have this and we talk you know
a couple of times a week like just reach
out to the people that you think are
cool
like if you reach out to them maybe
you'll make a new friend and maybe you
have another cool person in your life so
that's why you're
dating down you're dating down a bit
chris
where should people go where should
people go let's say that there's some
some parents who really want to kind of
sink their teeth into what it is that
you do where should they head
i so i have two instagram accounts i
don't know
why but i have at three plain brothers
and at sev on matosian i publish
every single day you're absolutely right
i try to answer
all of my dms you can also go to
threeplanebrothers.com
and you can go to the patreon account
and and um
most everything on there is free but if
you subscribe i do voiceovers on the
videos
and i'll show you some like like i might
show avi catch 12 consecutive balls
but then on the patreon account you see
it took me 300 tries to get that video
so but i also go into the deeper stuff
that we talked about in the beginning
and i try to share with people hey this
is why i did this this
is why i didn't um yell at him here this
is why i did yell at him here and i
i go into detail so those are all the
places instagram patreon but if you just
pick one place they'll all end up
you'll see the whole three plain
brothers world and thank you to everyone
and especially yourself for recognizing
um
the contribution because it's um and at
the end of the day i just want to add
value to people's lives
you're doing it man you really really
are are we
is it a sort of a genuine con
consideration that you've got
to write something to try and formalize
this structure down
um yeah it um i've outlined it like
three or four times it's just
really it's like i have this motorcycle
sitting in my driveway i know we're
wrapping this
up i have this motorcycle sitting in my
driveway for a year that i want to sell
but i had to tell my wife you must take
the kids away from me because i'm like a
crack addict
i'm like so i can spend 10 minutes
online getting this motorcycle online
because if i
i don't know when i would write a book
because i'm just so obsessed with just
being with the kids do you know what i
do you know what i'd what i'd do if i
was you
um and this is this is the easiest way
that i know of for anyone who has an
idea in their mind that they want to
structure
formalizing structure but doesn't have
the time to do it
i would just box off a day i would get
a buddy that you know really well that
understands what you're talking about i
would get him behind the camera i'd set
it up in either a studio rent out a
space or do it in your house
and i would just fill yourself full of
caffeine and speak to camera
for like 10 hours and then you're gonna
have
a 10 hour webinar
big chunk of work that you can put on
teachable or kajabi and you can have
as long as you'll need to do a little
bit of prep maybe a couple of days prep
but today what we've done today if you
flesh that out
and [ __ ] man you can make you would make
so much money and have such an impact
with that overnight um so i'm one for
one and if you want to
see this uploaded the three playing
brothers
um protocol for how to raise your kids
to be superhumans
comment below and uh maybe we'll be able
to get that done by the end of the year
thank you chris brother thank you so
much for your time i'll catch you next
time
[Music]
bye
[Music]